[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bernard
et
m
[Musique]
grâce à la grève de l'hygiène beaucoup
moins dangereuse que la grève de la faim
de plus en plus de gens peuvent accéder
à la contestation
aujourd'hui nous sommes rendus chez une
des grévistes qui pratique cette
nouvelle méthode de lutte
madame solange picot les bolides
[Musique]
solange quand vous commencez votre rêve
en 1975 janvier très exactement quand
j'ai pris conscience des événements du
sud est asiatique j'ai voulu protester
comme vous fait j'ai cessé de me brosser
les dents et à peine huit mois plus tard
vous vous livrez un autre combat c'est
exact al'annonce de mise en place de
gilles nucléaire en europe
mon sang n'a fait qu'un tour et j'ai
menacé de ne plus me laver les pieds
cependant les missiles sont construits
et vous mettez votre menace à exécution
ils étaient prévenus
et puis c'est 78
oui en solidarité avec les bébés phoques
je casse ma douce et des commandes
jusqu'à nouvel ordre mais quoi faire
pourtant vous n'êtes pas entendu en 79
les massacres continuent alors vous dire
si c'est votre rêve
et oui je fais mur est définitivement ma
salle de bain et brûlé tous mes gants de
toilette et puis soudain une partie de
l'opinion publique vous lâche on vous
reproche d'aller trop loin quand vous
décidez de ne plus vous l'avez les
aisselles et coûté tant qu'il restera
sur terre un seul pays vous m'entendez
bien seul ou ne respectera pas les
droits de l'homme qu'on ne compte pas
sur moi pour nettoyer pas plus les
aisselles que solange sur l'enjeu vous
irez vraiment jusqu'au bout
je me suis donné toute entière à mes
idées je ne reculerai pas
merci beaucoup
ce pic où vous devez être fier d'être le
mari d'une militante dur oui oui mais en
face et c'est pas tous les jours facile
vous souffrez de sentir votre femme dans
cet état de la sentir dans cet état en
louis avait beaucoup beaucoup et puis il
ya cette solitude voyez-vous éprouvante
si éprouvante vous voulez dire que vos
amis vous ne laisse au oui oui surtout
depuis qu'elle a refusé les deux caisses
de savons qu envoyer la croix rouge
alors là oui et votre famille ne vous
soutient pas donc le jeudi 6 par
téléphone uniquement par téléphone
il faut les comprendre est-ce que vous
pensez que les récents événements et les
déclarations du général san aux à gauche
maintenant
nous vous en supplie taisez vous il
n'est pas encore au courant non
justement en ce moment je suis en train
d'écrire au président des états unis
pour qu'ils règlent au plus vite toute
cette histoire d'amérique centrale
la menace est d'entraîner dans la grève
son beau frère et sa femme qui est une
femme qui alors là non vous écrivez
souvent président des états unis
tous les jours depuis cinq ans tous les
jours ainsi qu'aux premiers secrétaires
du reste d'ailleurs tous les jours tel
quel sur leurs réactions
elles sont embêtés sont très très embêté
ça ils sentent bien qu'il faut qu'il
fasse très attention parce qu'au
prochain troubles mondiaux enfin moi en
tous les cas on tiendrait pas le coup
quand j'ai rangé sa 10e gagner je gagne
[Musique]
ils ont libéré les prisonniers
politiques urbaniste ans ils ont cédé
leurs mots les mains
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non pas les connaît c'est pour les
ségrégationnistes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui c'est vrai j'ai été lolita c'est
vrai j'ai été sept femmes qu'on
pouponner qu'on dorlote mais maintenant
c'est fini maintenant je me sens forte
et solide
je cherche un homme mais pas n'importe
quel homme je cherche un homme qui me
traitent par l'enfant a tardé parce que
c'est pas gentil gentil que moi j'aime
pas ça du tout et puis que c'est celui
qui dit qui y est même à la monotonie de
la vie commune a endormi en au coeur la
prud'homie d'essence pour ranimer la
flamme vacillante du désir nous
aimerions rencontré deux messieurs bien
sous tous rapports qui partagerait avec
nous lève 6 de l'avenue bosquet une
ingestion de la sonatrach société de
diffusion des engins tractable à haut
niveau de rendement
et
et maintenant les sports allez les
garçons et bien oui c'est pierre
blanchet qui vous parle en direct dans
l'engarran sous se déroule actuellement
la finale comptant pour le simple
messieurs qui oppose bien sûr le suédois
bjorn borg à l'américain jimmy connors
et à l'heure où je vous parle c'est borg
qui parce qu'au nord ce qui passe à borg
qui passent là connor ce qui passe à
borg qui passe me connor ce qui passe à
bord qui passa à connor et comme convenu
je vous retrouve dans un petit quart
d'heure match sans surprise hier soir
salle nadeau comptant pour la coupe de
france du tireur de couverture qui
opposait la jeune brestoise jeanine
barrois haut savoyard en soi big but un
résultat vous allez le voir très attendu
très attendu ce qui explique sans doute
la faible assistance lors de cette
compétition
les deux concurrents s'observent et se
font évidemment les qualités ce visage
ils vont se mettre au lit c'est un début
de match vraiment très classique tout
cette traditionnelle
encore douteuse demi et voilà c'est
parti
c'est parti sur vous allez le vab suite
à un premier tir et latérale de big ben
qui n'inquiète pas vraiment jeannine
marois qui va répliquer par une habile
prise de draps à laquelle bute à son
tour réplique par un superbe ramener
découvrant qui abuse carrément le public
est venu pour s'amuser à ce moment là on
croit encore que le match ressemblait le
public y croit lui même en plus dans les
puits en juillet c'est un bédard hautes
herbes et d'arbres sans aucun brio 2 be
good on aura salue au passage la
présence dans le public du sympathique
ce dossier de l'école ou bruguier match
retour le 18 dans la chambre de métiers
d'homme fort mantel 27 rue lavoisier à
nantes
grâce aux récents travaux du professeur
hubert bagnole on sait maintenant que le
maréchal de turenne savez le grec le
latin monter un cheval sauvage se battre
à un contre sens dans ses menus est
escaladé un fortin jouer du tambour
chanter des romances tirer à l'arc bus
parler poésie et diplomatie mais qu'à
chaque fois qu'il faisait pipi il s'en
foutait place en pantalon leur rally de
monte cristo a fait très peu de morts
cette année les organisateurs accusent
le beau temps et atom c'est évidemment
un lapsus puma fait derrière je cite le
ministre est con comme un balai je
voulais évidemment dire le ministre est
intelligent comme un balai il est tombé
par terre et très très sportivement je
dois dire le borgne il est de ceux qui
étaient là
il a d'ailleurs relevé psy est tombé
c'est plusieurs bons et la cc borg qui
parce qu'au nord qui passe à borg qui
passa connors comme convenu je vous
retrouve dans un petit quart d'heure
[Musique]
ce film dédié albert ben 10 fours qui le
premier a mis en lumière l'existence du
du grand des routes 81 ans plus tard
nous sommes fiers d'avoir pu prouver le
bien fondé de ces théories
après des années de recherches déçu
d'espoir toujours évanouie d'attendre
stérile l'avion enfin trouvé cette nous
semblait être une piste sérieuse
l'existence d'un terrain à du groupe et
malgré une nature hostile au relief
abrupt au piège d'innombrables où la
moindre piqûre de mouches pouvait être
mortel nous entreprises de nous mettre à
l'affût la tension due à la tente
d'atténuer les limites du supportable
lorsque soudain incroyable alors que
nous commencions à perdre espoir sous
nos yeux émerveillés apparu notre
premier du groupe quelle émotion pour
nous mais aussi quelle récompense
c'était un mal magnifique de l'espèce
dite des routes
il semble visiblement fatigué par son
voyage
comme l'avait si bien noté body foudre
il commençait par répandre cfro nomme
ces fameuses sécrétions glandulaires
odorantes qui permettent aux du grand de
communiquer entre eux et de marquer leur
territoire les fameux terrain à du gros
une constation aussi que sa fameuse
réputation de méfiance n'était pas
usurpée et ce n'est qu'après un long et
méthodique examen actifs qu'ils se
décident à habiter la petite horde
créative à le rejoindre
nous bénéficions d'une chance insolente
trois femelles accompagnait le gros mâle
une vieille d'une chimio ni une gageure
de l'espèce dite frontières comme le mal
d'ailleurs
et enfin un petit du grand femelle
encore non sevrés nous semble active
voici on pantois devant le spectacle qui
s'est déroulé sous nos yeux et dire que
certains pseudo scientifiques avaient
osé contester la théorie de body four
sur les origines le mad du grand tout en
affirmant d'une manière péremptoire que
son mode d'alimentation ne pouvait être
que végéter rien alors qu'il était de
toute évidence hommes niveau de toutes
les sociétés de primates celle des du
grande est à l'évidence très strictement
hiérarchisé et le rôle dominant du mal
ne faisait aucun doute
c'est au moment où nous progressions
afin d'améliorer notre observation qu'un
stupide incident failli tout remettre en
cause
ils nous avaient entendu et la petite
hors d'eux semblait soudain à kg est
fébrile surtout le gros mâle n'était-il
pas le chef du clan
tapis derrière notre frêle abri de
branchages ne nous apprêtions à subir sa
charge
lorsque curieusement très curieusement
il nous semble assister à des prémices
amoureux quel choc
le cri nuptiale du grand du gros main
elle venait de retentir dans sa sauvage
beauté
réécoutons le voulez vous plus aucun
doute
la prévenue a été le moment privilégié d
amour pour le dupont
maintenant le mal cherché une couche -
le afin d'y féconde et sa compagne comme
elle est et activiste x est maintenant
dans la femelle prenez l'initiative
amoureuse on abat les gracieux le
prémice truction se dérouler sous nos
yeux émerveillés mettant tour à tour en
relief la grâce de la femelle et la
puissance du mal sous les regards
meilleur du reste cloud
legrand ruth des dugongs avait commencé
beauté simple qu'elle était grandiose la
vision de ce couple de primates après
l'amour cette vieille femelle endormi
encore une fois l'observation in situ
venait bousculer bien des idées reçues
le rude terminer notre famille allait
reprendre son voyage le mâle
responsables chefs père fils et à man
s'apprête à se désaltérer une dernière
fois avant le long périple sous les yeux
attentifs de son enfant mais regardez
bien la vieille femelle
il semble qu'elle dorme eh bien non
arrivé au bout de son voyage et afin de
ne pas encombrer la horde
elle préfère mourir seul
les autres le savent et dignement
accepte la loi de l'espèce
la vertu il fallait nous rendre à
l'évidence n'étions pas sur un terrain
du grand mais sur le lieu sans doute
sacré où il venait s'éteindre cette
découverte
allez nous en étions sûr faire l'effet
d'une bombe dans le monde scientifique
je n'étais pas sans une certaine
tristesse une regardions s'éloigner la
horde toujours poussé plus loin par son
ancestrale instinct migratoires alors
que laguiole dans un dernier sursaut
pour échapper aux doigts glacées de la
mort leur adresser un dernier adieu dans
la lumière froide de cette fin de
journée
[Musique]
ah ah
le gros chat à manger la petite souris
c'est compris bon et bien
labrèche tenait là bref de gains gallois
souffle pas y occupe égard n 9 a fait de
bons bateaux l'homme suit houle du tout
vous pouvez me répéter ce que vient de
dire on n'écoutait pas suis toujours
rêver c'est comme d'habitude au bord et
vous allez aller au piquet suis tout
près d'y ranger bateau au pic est mort
mais il n'y a pas de même à dar voilà
deux jours que vous devriez savoir le
gros chat a mangé la petite souris et
vous n'êtes pas capable de le lire au
piquet oui lorca et buzz depuis tout à
l'heure il ya un couteau coupe chez vous
le gros c'est bien la malheureuse ce
matin
[Musique]
vous allez m'écrire à prat suis mort
déjà calés que sur son cahier de dicter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à la dictée tout le monde et près de
décoller quand les chevaux que ça me
retombe en pleurs se savoure sa bosse
avec sur la tête du fonds ne bave pas
qu'on écrive à la brèche contours du
club herbretais du petit canari sa
[Musique]
section 4,5 à cet angle boulevard saint
germain et vouloir ça michel quart
numéro 8
et celui à celui là il est au piquet il
fait ses bâtons capitaine parfait il
prendre la tête et vous savez capitaine
que si vous me les enlever tous les
quarts d'heure ils ne seront jamais ni
lire ni écrire sur twitter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir cette semaine k comme kangourou
nous avons
[Musique]
au bout en bout
au cas où
[Musique]
c'est borg qui passe à connor ce qui
passe à borg et banque passe à connor ce
qui passe à borg qui passe à connor ce
qui passe à borg bord qui passe bonsoir
à tous et à toutes
on cerne e mail bonsoir jocelyne
bienvenue attestons détestant puisque
nous sommes en avril mois s'il en est
que l'on achète ses chaussures nous
allons vous aider à faire votre choix en
testant pour vous deux modèles de
souliers
tout d'abord un escarpin français très
fin très agréable à regarder et ce
modèle étranger qui est comme on le voit
lait est trop petit alors noël laquelle
de ses deux chaussures choisir difficile
difficile de répondre jocelyne avant
d'avoir fait passer les deux tests que
nos amis connaissent bien maintenant
imperméabilité et robustesse vous avez
bien raison noël commençons tout d'abord
si vous le voulez bien par le test
d'imperméabilité qui est je vous le
rappelle la résistance à l'eau
à à la chaussure française a l'air de
très bien se comporter jocelyne mais oui
mais oui noël
voyons maintenant le soulier étrangers
merci noël votre avis noël a je crois
oui je crois quand même que je donnerais
un léger avantage à la sauce française
disons beau 2.1 et vous jocelyne en jeu
seraient beaucoup moins sévère que vous
noël et je ne donnerai quatre points
d'avancé à la chaussée aux français le
gentil josky mais le suspense reste
entier puisque je vous le rappelle
il nous reste le test de robustesse ou
la chaussure de fabrication étrangère
peut refaire son retard avant noël merci
jocelyne voyons maintenant comment vont
se comporter nos deux candidats aux
tests robustesse
ah oui je vous ai noël s'il vous plaît
aux mais dites moi s'il vous plaît que
le modèle étranger ne soit pas sans des
fourneaux elle enfin bon passons aux à
l'escarpin s'est doucement
[Applaudissements]
oui
qu'en pensez vous et cela ce n'est pas
facile and well as courage à ce qu'une
courage des dit
bon et bien puisqu'il leveaux je
donnerai un poids de plus à la chaussure
française des mots noël alors un deux
trois quatre cinq saga 0 c'est
indiscutable en avril pour vos
chaussures choisissez français le mois
prochain pour vous aider à choisir votre
cochon d'inde nous ferons passer nos
deux tests imperméabilité et robustesse
d'une part à ce petit rongeur français
et d'autre part à sera étranger avant
noël au bar jocelyne bonsoir
[Musique]
gris soir les eaux la chute d'un avion
de chasse sur la salle des fêtes de gris
soir les eaux pendant le bal annuel de
chris ware les eaux a fait 150 morts
dont aucun n'était originaire de chris
ware les eaux
c'est un véritable miracle
[Musique]